(upbeat music)
- We are trying McDonald's
in Israel right now.
- I'm not a huge, huge burger person,
so I think it'll be better kosher.
- I'm a pretty big
McDonald's fan in general.
I think it's the best of the fast food.
(upbeat music)
- We do not have this in America.
- They look a little bit
like mini mozzarella sticks.
- Inside there's corn and
mashed potatoes or something?
- I'm a little worried,
'cause it has real corn pieces in it.
- I love corn.
I (beeping) will eat corn bread all day.
It's sweet and savory,
and I'm a big sweet and savory person.
- Those are pretty good.
- This is really gross.
- It tastes kind of like a tofu nugget.
I wonder what's inside,
'cause I don't think it's cheese.
- It's a little bland.
- I have no clue what this is.
- I'm trying the Texas sauce.
- It smells like barbecue.
- So this is what
Israelis think Texans eat.
It's pretty accurate.
It tastes like barbecue sauce.
- Those are seriously really good.
(upbeat music)
I'm trying the MyMac Chicken.
- Is it a Big Mac or a MyMac?
- [Woman] It's a MyMac Chicken.
- Israel is a tech country.
It's like iMac, MyMac.
- [Woman] This is as big as my face.
- It's (beeping) huge.
- It looks really similar to what we have,
but it has the tahini sauce on it.
And everything fell out.
- It's got two crispy chickens in it.
- It tastes like a
chicken tender on a bun.
You don't really taste the tahini sauce.
- We really know how to do
fried chicken in America.
This fried chicken's crispy and nice,
but it's not like fried chicken, you know?
Kind of bland, actually.
(upbeat music)
- This is apparently what
Israelis think Americans
eat all the time because this is called
the Mega Big America.
- Las Vegas edition.
I am from Las Vegas.
- A very big patty.
Okay.
- This type of meat here
looks like an entire steak
and it's got kinda weird
granular stuff going on.
- It has tomatoes, lettuce, pickle, onion.
It kinda smells like a veggie patty.
- It smells just like meat, honestly.
- This'll be good. (laughing)
I'm not a big meat eater, but that's good.
It's really thick, too.
- Oh my God.
It's super dry.
- Super well done.
- The texture of the
meat's kind of somewhere
between hamburger and steak.
- Great (beeping) tomatoes.
- Israeli McDonald's, good to go.
- Israeli McDonald's was
more or less the same
as the American McDonald's.
- Pretty good.
Just like regular McDonald's.
- I would definitely get these again.
Corn sticks, they're the best.
- I give it A+, minus the corn sticks.
- Would eat, if it
weren't for all the other
great food in this earth.
(upbeat music)
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new channel.
- [Unison] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.